-That's how you do it
right there!
Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're here.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, this is exciting.
Tomorrow morning, Congress
will hold its first hearing
on UFOs in more than 50 years.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, now that all the problems
on Earth have been solved,
on to UFOs.
[ Laughter ]
Since 2004, 144 people
have called in a UFO sighting.
144 sightings.
That means you have
a better chance
of spotting a UFO
than a Home Depot employee.
[ Laughter ]
"Anyone here?
Anyone here?
Ugh, just forget it."
"Any --"
[ Applause ]
"Anyone?"
-"Anyone in here?"
-"I have to check out myself?"
-"Yeah."
-"Okay."
[ Laughter ]
"I hope this works."
-What?
-You guys see this?
Jeff Bezos and the White House
have been going back and forth
on Twitter
after President Biden blamed
corporations for inflation,
and Bezos blamed Biden's
stimulus plans.
Yeah.
Now Bezos is gonna buy Twitter
from Elon Musk
just to ban Biden.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, things are getting tense.
Right now, the CIA
is spying on Bezos,
and Alexa is spying on Biden.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. It's Amazon
versus the government.
So now we know
how the drone war will begin.
[ Laughter ]
Well, on Saturday,
former President Trump
held a rally in Austin, Texas,
and he said pretty much
what you'd expect.
So instead of showing
the same clips
that you've seen
a million times,
we're gonna try a new piece
called "Trump With No Context."
Enjoy.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Uh...
Ahh...
Aah!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
[ Applause ]
-Yep.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Meanwhile, Senate GOP leader,
Mitch McConnell,
spent his weekend in Ukraine,
where he met
with President Zelenskyy.
Can we see a photo of them?
Yeah, wow.
[ Laughter ]
Zelenskyy looks like a guy
meeting his new stepdad
for the first time.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm not calling you dad."
Well, this is big.
Today, McDonald's announced
that, after more than
three decades in Russia,
they're selling their business
and completely
leaving the country.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
It's sad news for Russians
who will now probably
live 20 years longer.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, a Russian guy
is frantically sprinting
to McDonald's to try and redeem
his "Monopoly" stickers.
"Please,
I just got Baltic Avenue!
I just got Baltic!"
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news.
I saw that the candy company
Mars Wrigley has recalled
some varieties of Starburst,
Skittles, and Lifesavers,
because they could
contain metal.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Actually, Mars didn't
recall the candies.
They just relabeled them
all jaw breakers.
[ Laughter ]
Some travel news.
I heard that the TSA
is bringing in more agents
to prepare
for the summer-vacation rush.
That's great,
but it's not very comforting
to know that a TSA agent
is considered a summer job.
[ Laughter ]
"You can go.
You can go.
You can go."
[ Laughter continues ]
"You can go."
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, you can go."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"You can go."
That's right.
They're starting to hire now
for the summer rush.
We're two weeks from June.
[ Laughter ]
I guess the training
is basically, "Here's the wand.
Enjoy."
[ Laughter ]
By the time
you're done training,
you'll know how to say,
"This lane is closed,"
in six different languages.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this is fun.
The University of Oklahoma
just signed a new player,
and his name is pretty unique.
Check this out.
-The Oklahoma Sooners got
a JUCO transfer quarterback.
His name?
General Booty.
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-What?
-General Booty.
Such a proud day for his
parents, Pirate and Shake Your.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Booty.
-General Booty, yeah.
I have a feeling his first word
as a baby was, "Why?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, he signed
to play at Oklahoma.
It's nice to hear
about a booty call
that actually ended
in commitment.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this --
a teenager in Philadelphia
just broke a 57-year-old record
after running a mile
in under four minutes.
-Ooh.
-And in response, his classmate
was like, "All right.
So I'll take that as a no,
you don't want
to go to prom with me.
Okay. All right. Fine."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, finally guys,
it's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Pros and cons
and pros and cons and pros ♪
-Now, tonight,
we'll be taking a look
at the pros and cons of
JetBlue buying Spirit Airlines.
It was just announced
that JetBlue
is attempting to purchase
Spirit Airlines.
Yeah, this could mean a lot
of changes to the way we fly,
so let's take a look
at the pros and cons
of JetBlue
buying Spirit Airlines.
Here we go.
Pro --
JetBlue is offering
to buy Spirit Airlines
for $33 a share.
Con -- Spirit is like,
"Heck, you can take
the whole plane for $25."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- JetBlue promises
to bring all-new features
to Spirit planes.
Con -- like "pilots."
[ Laughter ]
You're gonna want those.
[ Applause ]
Pro -- now the two airlines
can join forces
and get back to doing
what they do best.
Con -- inventing new ways
to charge for luggage.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Uh, it's too small.
It's too small.
You gotta pay $5.
Small luggage."
[ Laughter ]
-"It's got a handle."
-"Yeah. Oh, it's a wallet.
Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
Pro -- JetBlue
is attempting the purchase
through a hostile takeover.
Con -- a hostile takeover
is how Spirit
describes
their boarding process.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I have Baltic!
I have Baltic!"
[ Applause ]
Pro -- JetBlue
wanted to sit down
with Spirit Airlines
and make a deal.
Con --
Spirit doesn't do "seats."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Everyone just standing, hold --
[ Laughter ]
Hold the pole.
-"Next.
Go ahead."
-"You can go ahead."
[ Laughter ]
"You can go ahead, if you want."
-"Wait, wait, wait."
-"You can fly it, if you want.
I don't care."
[ Laughter ]
-"Wait, stop.
Where'd you get those shoes?"
[ Laughter ]
-Pro -- Spirit stockholders
have a lot of questions.
Con -- like,
"How drunk was I
when I bought stock
in Spirit Airlines?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pro -- Spirit's stock rose
in anticipation of the merger.
Con -- it's the first time
anything from Spirit
has ever gained altitude.
"Oh, yeah, we did it!"
[ Applause ]
And, finally, pro --
Spirit and JetBlue
will be combining forces.
Con --
to create "Spue Airlines."
There you have it.
Those are the "Pros and Cons."
We have a great show!